welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and the thor love and thunder trailer
shows us an original recipe thor getting
back into a shape that reflects his
improving mental health following his
intense battle with depression in
avengers end game and after thanos
almost found out if thor was secretly a
birthday cake towards the end of a
vendor's end game the odinson knows that
he needs to be in top physical form to
battle the bloody blight that is gore
the godbutcher but hold on now i'm no
gym expert but those chains don't seem
like they were originally meant to be
used to burn calories just who was this
wumbo sized skeleton that was imprisoned
pre for workout could this skeleton
actually be teasing more of marvel phase
four's multiverse plans to come well we
are the speculation nation are we not so
let's speculate my nerd babies and
before i continue make sure to hit up
new rockstarsmerch.com so that you can
pick up our latest obsession shirt tomb
of the moon god and this shirt is
selling out very quickly so please head
on over to new rochester's merch.com
because the shirt is not going to last
forever pick it up today or just
anything else we have because we have a
lot of cool nerd [ __ ] now let's take a
look at the remains of this poor person
of preposterous proportions because this
is a weird looking skeleton no i mean
well other than the fact that they used
to be the size of your average chuck e
cheese location but the thing that's
really weird to me is the skull because
look at the shape of this thing that is
one wildly extra bulbous dome but
another obvious but very important thing
to note here is that well this giant ass
person was a giant ass prisoner at the
moment of his death but why and for what
reason well as you might already know by
now that earlier on in the trailer we
get this shot of korg and thor standing
at a cliff looking at the remains of a
giant kaiju of a god named falagar which
was ripped straight out of the pages of
jason aaron's 2012 run of thor god of
thunder the very same run that
introduces gore the god butcher to the
marvel universe as an absolute savage of
a beast who apparently can kill the
freaking beastly patron god of the
galactic frontier a cosmic serial killer
unlike anything the pantheons of the
universe have seen before and it's also
during that run that we learned that
gore the godbutcher spent thousands of
years not just butchering gods but also
torturing and interrogating the gods
with a prime example being how he
chained up a poor young version of thor
in thor god of thunder issue 4 while
trying to get him to betray his kingdom
by giving up super important asgardian
secrets like i don't know the location
of asgard who his daddy is and what does
he do now the reason why i'm saying all
this is because to me the most likely
person that used to own the skeletal
remains of an nba all-star of a prisoner
is none other than a watcher yes
marvel's favorite cosmic stalkers with
enlarged gerber baby heads you know
watu's people because as we know from
the marvel comics as well as their first
live-action appearance during stan lee's
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 cameo uatu
is not the only watcher in the marvel
universe they actually are a super
evolved race of people that originally
hail from the planet t-37x in the comics
and you guys might be saying right now
alright empty sure the melons of the
guardian's two watchers are indeed
massive and weird looking but they're
not that massive that dude was huge like
that big ass prisoner could probably
hold two of those watchers from
guardians 2 in each hand and eat them
like candy bars however much like the
marvel comics and watch of the watcher
from what if the watchers have
historically been able to manipulate
their size so technically there really
isn't an average size of a watcher
especially because if you think about it
the watchers have to watch on so many
different levels of the marvel cinematic
universe with even the microscopic
quantum realm being within the purview
of guatu the peeping creeper of a
watcher so if a watcher were to be
murdered their corpse could literally be
found at any size which is what i
believe happened here after gore the god
butcher chained up one of the live
action mcu's universe's watchers for the
express purpose of extracting
information out of them with the
cruelest of torturing techniques that
gore told a torture thor made even a god
of torture tell gore where his own kids
were hiding one time like that is some
hardcore [ __ ] the god of torture sold
out his own kids now traditional banks
have drawbacks 35 overdraft fees bad
customer service no cash back on debit
purchases what the heck's up with that
albert is completely different from any
bank account you've ever used because
albert is free to sign up for and super
easy to use check out the albert card
when you get paid onto your albert card
albert can get your paycheck to your
card up to two days early exact timing
depends on your employer's payment
schedule and albert also doesn't charge
overdraft fees ever they let you advance
up to 250 from your next paycheck and
pay it back with no interest and no
credit check managing your personal
finances can be hard and stressful
albert has a team of financial experts
they call geniuses that will look into
your situation and help you make a plan
and answer any questions if you get
stuck they have an easy to use app
interface and lots of great tools to
help you save money so click the link in
the description box below or go to
albert.com rockstars to download the
albert app today that's albert.com
rockstars and for a limited time when
you open a checking account and connect
a qualifying direct deposit you'll get
150 dollars in my opinion the watchers
would be a very high priority on for the
god butcher's kill list for two obvious
reasons first of course being that
they're the watchers and gore's beef
with the gods is that they all just sat
by and watched as his mother his son and
his pregnant wife all died from the
terribly horrific conditions of his home
planet so this gore the god watching
dude is going to have a huge beef with
this race of silent observers whose
stupid oath of non-interference have led
to the sufferings of so many mortals
across the universe who just needed a
simple helping hand and secondly much
like gore tortured thor for the location
of asgard in the comics gore the
godbutcher highly likely could have
tortured a watcher for the location of
the other watchers in the universe so
that he could lay waste to their entire
kind which is something i can very much
see being the case considering how hard
it is to find even one watcher to begin
with and if all of his people are gone
this also allows owatu the watcher to
have an even more important role in the
mcu if he's now the last of his overly
observant kind this would all also make
sense considering the corpse of the god
falagar that we see earlier on in the
trailer because at the beginning of that
thor god of thunder comic run with gore
thor keeps coming across the corpses of
dead gods which is what causes thor to
first realize that there is a serial
killing heathen that is bringing that
unholy heat to a heliopolis near you so
due to the massive amounts of
inspiration this movie looks like it's
taking from its original comic run the
presence of this giant corpse is likely
hinting at a dead godlike being like
falagar and the watchers are the biggest
fit because check out the side by side
of this dead watcher from the comics and
this dead skeleton i think their skulls
match pretty well however the watchers
are not the only big giants in the mcu
that could potentially fit this size
profile because i would be remiss if i
did not mention the hard-working dwarves
of nadivalier as they are very much the
only other giants in the mcu that aren't
frosty or spicy flavored giants and
considering that yetri did reveal to us
all that thanos wiped out all of the
dwarves after forcing them to make his
magic mitten this could be one of those
dwarves that thanos killed during his
thanos quest of self-actualization
however considering how different this
environment looks in the trailer to that
of the dwarf forge world i'm more keen
to lean on the watchers being the owners
of one of these skeletons because
dwarves don't really have that god-like
status that powerful entities like the
asgardians the inead the wu-tang clan or
the celestials do so i'm thinking that
was probably a watcher and that makes
sense considering the watchers are going
to play a big part moving forward in the
mcu so it makes sense for marvel studios
to start leaving little teases about the
history of the watchers in the mcu but
what's also scary here is that in that
same comic run gore tries to make
something called a god
bomb and he tortures people to try to
find the people who know how to make it
so maybe he's using the watchers to try
to find out how to make a god bomb and
destroy all the gods in the universe
what do you guys think do you guys think
that this skeleton could be a watcher or
do you think it could be somebody else
let us know in the comment section below
but anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me
mastertainment on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some really weird [ __ ] and
really interesting theories but more
importantly you can follow new rockstars
wherever we are on the internet and if
you do on youtube make sure you hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video which is every day so you don't
want to miss any uploads but again
thanks again for watching i love you
guys so much and i'll see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]
you